the new BMW m6 gran coupe a is an
elegant car with off-the-charts
performance BMWs M division has been
producing amped up versions of the
company's regular production models for
over 40 years now the company's first
entry in the four-door coupe a segment
has received the coveted m badge as well
that means more than just aggressive
styling however it brings the divisions
Motorsports experience to a car meant
for the street
that was a product manager York Hammond
says the m division offers engineers the
chance to try out new technology that
will only later be used in BMWs
mass-produced models the m division has
used lightweight construction components
such as carbon fiber for years a
material that is now being used in BMWs
regular production models to compound
breaking technology is another factor
here which has also migrated to the most
powerful standard-issue BMWs a game-mode
nvm it at basildon motohashi on carbon
fiber reinforced plastic is used in the
car's roof for instance but all this
comes at a price the M version of the
6-series gran coupe a constant nearly
fifty thousand euros more than the base
model the car's design reflects its
high-tech nature form follows function
here engineers have reworked the shell
to optimize engine cooling and
aerodynamics the four-door coupe a's
wheelbase is 11 centimeters longer than
the two-door versions in addition to the
high-performance compound brakes carbon
ceramic alternatives are also available
for chromed exhaust pipes adorn the
car's rear sending a clear signal to
drivers behind the m6 and should they
fail to appreciate the visuals they make
quite a sound as well
the m6 gran coupe a comes into its own
on back roads the heart of this
high-performance machine is its high
revving v8 with m twinpower turbo
technology it's good for 412 kilowatts
which translates to 560 horsepower the
engine develops its maximum torque of
680 Newton meters at low revs and takes
the sizeable Kupe to 100 4.2 seconds but
drivers who take advantage of all that
power are unlikely to match the
manufacturers overall fuel economy
figure of nine point nine litres per 100
kilometers the interior combines
dynamism and elegance the sporty
leather-wrapped steering wheel features
stitching in the M divisions colors the
transmission is a seven-speed
double-clutch model the cockpit is
oriented towards the driver as is proper
for a sports car
m sport seats are standard for the
driver and front passenger the seats are
individually adjustable and provide
plenty of comfort on the road the rear
bench also offers room to relax
the m-series is a favorite amongst
automotive high tech fans around the
world
dr. B meet artists Venezia's start the
US is the main market for bmw's
high-performance subsidiary explains
York Hammond but there are plenty of
fans in Europe as well in Germany
Britain from Switzerland for example is
Pattaya knob off in the fight somebody
and growing markets and Asia are also
vital talk to you I lived in a shelter
from vector it's not all high tech
performance however the m6 gran coupe a
can also do its duty as a daily errand
runner the trunk has a capacity of 460
litres with the rear bench up with the
seats down it can pack in 1200 leaders
tech-savvy drivers can choose their own
array of settings and save their choices
with a button on the steering wheel
the mice and phosphor our contestar
robots I think the m6 gran coupe a is
best experienced on big wide
straightaways but even on curves the
two-ton car feels like the suspension is
tight without being excessively hard and
if you step on the gas the car lunches
forwards with brute force the brakes
require some familiarity though they
combined hardness and precision that are
usually only found in supercars from
super [ __ ] Bobby happened the only
thing that diminishes the fun are the
high co2 emissions oh and the price the
m6 gran coupe a starts at one hundred
twenty eight thousand eight hundred
euros in Germany